[music]
>> How many of you tried learning one verse
in this 30 minutes?
At least one verse.
Brother, you speak one more half an
hour, I'll memorize one more.
One verse?
By the way, as a general rule,
when the homework for the revision of
both cross-checking of the surah names
as well as
the revision of the Quranic verses is
concerned, whenever the homework time
starts, all are supposed to close their
files.
Keep the papers inside, the verses
inside. None are allowed to refer then.
All things go inside.
I request everyone to put the verses
sheet inside. All participants,
put the verses inside.
But we already failed now, brother.
Sorry? We already failed now for today.
No, inshallah.
I'll yet give you a chance, and I know
that inshallah you would be able to do
it. Inshallah.
Okay, let us quickly start with brother
Iman.
Can you pass on the mic to brother Iman,
and all all the candidates, put the file
and the papers inside.
Brother Iman,
you said 10 verses, you know with 90%
and above accuracy, inshallah, and 12
verses you said 60%. So, at least
give me those 10 verses.
Arabic, reference, and the translation.
Start.
Auzubillahiminashaitanirajim.
Bismillahirahmanirahim.
Surah Al-Baqarah, chapter number two,
verse number 111.
They say, "None shall enter paradise
unless he be a Jew or a Christian."
These are their vain desires.
Say, "Produce your proof if you're
truthful." Masha Allah. Surah
Al-Baqarah, chapter number two, verse
number 143.
That means, "We have made you an ummah
which is justly balanced, and we have
made a witness over We have made you as
a witness over mankind, and messenger
Muhammad as a witness over you." Masha
Allah. Then Surah Al-Imran, chapter
number three, verse number 64.
>> [clears throat]
>> "O people of the book, come to common
terms as between us and you,
that we worship none but Allah, and we
associate no partners with him, and we
erect no lords and patrons besides
Allah,
and if they turn back, say, "Bear
witness that we are Muslims, at least
bowing our will to Allah Subhana Wa
Ta'ala." Masha Allah. Yeah. Then Surah
Jazakallah, brother.
You can hold on to the mic, inshallah.
Masha Allah, the accuracy is 100%.
Alhamdulillah. If not 100%, I would say
at least
95% and above. Alhamdulillah.
One thing is there are different styles
of learning the Quranic verses.
And one such style is what you have
learned.
But there is a style of learning the
verse of the Quran which is far superior
than this.
I basically,
whether I learn
the surah names or whether I learn the
Quranic verses,
I take into consideration that during my
talk,
if I have to give the same verse, for me
to be effective, what is the best way to
learn the Quranic verse?
One way is the way as you're saying it,
that you learn the Arabic, the complete
verse,
and then you give the English
translation.
But the more effective way, which would
be more helpful to you
in bringing an impact
in your
dawah talk or in any of your Islamic
talks is you learn the verses part
Arabic, its translation, and then little
Arabic, its translation. You break the
verses into different parts.
And alhamdulillah,
if you can learn the verses of the Quran
this way,
then inshallah,
the impact would be far superior.
There will be an impact if you quote the
Arabic,
you know, the levels of impact are
different. Some people can quote only
the reference.
Neither English
nor the Arabic. Some can quote the
reference and the English. Yes, the
impact is there.
Some people can quote the reference,
give the entire Arabic and the entire
translation. Third level, very good.
But the best,
the most high
in terms of memorizing the Quranic
verses with translation is that you give
the reference and split the verse into
different parts.
Say the Arabic
and then the English translation. For
example,
Surah Al-Ikhlas, chapter number 112,
verses one to four. Allah Tabaraka Wa
Ta'ala says,
"Qul Hu Allahu Ahad. Say, He is Allah,
one and only. Allahus Samad. Allah, the
absolute and eternal. Lam Yalid Wa Lam
Yulad. He begets not, nor is He
begotten. Wa Lam Yakul Lahu Kufuwan
Ahad. And there is none like unto Him."
See the impact?
When you are delivering talks on Islam
to an audience
which if it consists of non-Muslims and
Muslims together,
Muslims, masha Allah,
would definitely know
your authority over the subject,
and non-Muslims too would realize it.
It would give such a good impression to
them
that this man who is speaking
is an authority on the subject.
And unless you don't win the confidence,
how would you be able to convince them
about Islam?
And this is one of the best ways, and
this Quran has an effect.
I'm sorry to say,
no translation of the Quran can have the
same effect the way as Arabic can have.
No translation, whether it be in
English, Urdu,
Tamil, Chinese, Japanese,
Malay,
no translation.
And we learned that in the morning
session,
that translation is a human handiwork.
Can it have the same impact like that of
the Arabic?
Definitely not.
Yes, it can have an impact, even if you
don't know Arabic, but with the Arabic,
the impact that which it can create
is phenomenal.
And alhamdulillah,
I would not be exaggerating
if I have to say that masha Allah,
one of the best speakers
whom I have seen personally in my life
who can quote the Arabic,
split the verse into different parts,
and be impactful with the English is
none other than Farik.
Alhamdulillah. By the grace of Allah
Subhana Wa Ta'ala,
he has done his Hifz-ul-Quran,
and when he gives the speeches,
the most confident I have found any
speaker who comes on BST,
who can give the Arabic,
split it into different parts with the
English,
is none other than him. Not even Dr.
Zakir Naik, for your information.
Dr. Zakir Naik himself
humbly agrees, and he would agree to it
as well.
But most of the verses,
he knows Arabic as well as the English,
but
masha Allah, the training that which
Farik has got, and not just Farik,
alhamdulillah, there are other students
as well from IAS, brother Arsh, and
there are masha Allah other students as
well who have learned this technique.
The technique of learning the Quranic
verses in parts.
Give an Arabic portion
and then the translation.
Arabic, translation. And in this way,
you can even work on your modulation.
Modulation,
which you will inshallah be learning the
day after tomorrow, inshallah,
the techniques,
and you will learn how important is
modulation in your speech.
And one of the ways how you can create
an impact on your audiences who are
listening to you is by modulation.
And this way, by learning the Quranic
verses, one modulation for the Arabic.
Qul Hu Allahu Ahad. Say, He is Allah,
the one and only. Allahus Samad. Allah,
the absolute and eternal. Lam Yalid Wa
Lam Yulad. He begets not, nor was He
begotten.
Different modulation
for Arabic, different modulation for
English translation.
You would see it
Brothers, masha Allah,
may have delivered hundreds of lectures,
if not hundreds, at least 10 to 20
lectures.
You would yourself see the impact that
which it is creating if you learn the
way as I've told you.
Reference
part Arabic, part translation.
Part Arabic, part translation.
Different modulation.
Different modulation, sometimes high
pitch for Arabic
and
low pitch for English. Or sometimes low
pitch for Arabic, high pitch for
English.
You can vary it.
And inshallah, the impact would be
phenomenal.
Would be breathtaking.
So, if you want to excel and you want to
want to excel and you want to be
inshallah in the excellent category of
those participants in the Quranic
verses.
area and one such important evaluation
for this Dawah training program is your
Quranic verses.
A very important.
And there is a separate rating all
together for that.
Quranic verses.
And if you want to excel in this, the
best is
reference part Arabic, part English.
Second best
reference full Arabic, full English.
I don't want to say the third and the
fourth because
inshallah
I know that inshallah if you strive, you
will all be at least be able to reach
the level two.
That is give the reference
Arabic and English.
And I know inshallah if you strive
more than 50% of the participants here
would be able to even reach the level
one.
Inshallah.
More than 50%.
And when I say more than 50%, it can
even be 90%. 99% as well.
>> [music]
[music]